were you born in hawaii i wasn't born in
hawaii i was born here in san francisco
but i
did a lot of my growing up there so yeah
so it was it was amazing i don't know
i don't think no tell me
[Laughter]
what's more you say for years i've
always said when we were there you gave
me a big speech like this is my land
[Laughter]
[Music]
now all of a sudden san fran that was
san fran then i transferred
but we were there
[Laughter]
this is a cliff where i was born
hawaii was beautiful beautiful uh
you know mountainside and lushness and
and uh we shot in this beautiful place
called kualoa ranch where uh
jurassic park the original jurassic park
was shot and the ones uh after that as
well and
it was just amazing but you didn't like
it he hated it no no this is the problem
i didn't i didn't like it at all i mean
outside of the the spiritual grounds
that you took me to and i swore
you even sung a song you were like
i have to share that one we'll talk
about it later
like you were like
don't you didn't like these films no not
at all i i
i think the technical term is a scaredy
cat
i never saw horror movies growing up uh
i was too terrified
and obviously i'm a huge horror fan now
if you saw my itunes list over the last
year you'd say i think we have a problem
um but it's uh it's phenomenal i don't
think i'm
my name is the one that you see and say
can't wait to see a horror movie from
that guy
but the original script came to me and
it's actually uh an incredible story of
family and so it's to me
you can't tell by looking at the poster
we can show that again but it is a love
letter to my kids
it's about what would you do uh as a
parent what what extremes would you go
to to protect your kids
and is this true that this film you
originally weren't going to be in
well we had just had our second child
and i was about to do mary poppins and
so i was in a sort of
general feeling of joy i didn't know if
i wanted to go towards the darkness of
the pitch that he'd given me for this
film
and then i i'd mentioned a friend of
mine too john when he pitched me i said
oh you should call so-and-so
and um and so so-and-so is so good
so he did call so-and-so and you didn't
center the script admittedly she wasn't
sort of hired but
um so close but so good and then i read
the script and i was like you need to
call her and fire her
are you still friends with her we are
until the movie comes out and then she's
like
and john for you obviously lovely that
emily wants to be in the first
absolutely but as a director is it then
weird giving your life partner notes
it it was weird because i was very
nervous about to be honest i think we
both were
before we started shooting she said are
you nervous and i said i'm terrified and
she said oh
good me too um i think it's one of those
things where people think because we're
both
in the same business we have the same
experiences but i've actually never been
on set with her scene how she worked
i'd heard she was a diva and i
can't just emily out of her trailer
stuff like that it's like oh and um
no but i think what it was is and it
sounds really
sappy but it's true i think it's the
greatest collaboration i've ever had in
my career i
i've never seen her work and when you
are actually in the room and she does
what she does it
honestly it changes the air in the room
everyone is just completely and totally
stunned by what she does
was that british people are notoriously
terrible at taking compliments would you
agree just like
this oh that's
that's actually what she did we first
met he was like i just want to get out
of the way i'm a huge fan of yours
you weren't cool at all there was none
of that actually uh i don't know your
work you were a proper fan of this
full stalker status yeah i was just like
hey
you want to go on a date with me
tell people how many is this true how
many times have you seen devil where's
brother
i mean not 75 give or take 72.
no it's one of those things that back in
the day us elderly people used to
channel surf
and um no one does that anymore but
like i said so cruel no it's just one of
those movies that whatever whenever
you're going through the channels you
just stop and you
i mean look has anyone seen the film
here probably
[Applause]
there's a sort of montage sequence where
annie hathaway's got
numerous fabulous outfits that they go
through and john one day i came home
and he was watching it and and he was
watching the montage bit and he goes
and that's my favorite outfit
well i couldn't get annie and so
[Laughter]
now rock your character's name is dr
smolder bravestone
yes and so all the characters have
strengths so one of your strengths is
the smoldering an actual smolder yes it
just takes over
uh and i have no control of it and did
you know you could smolder
like did you kind of think yeah when you
were doing you read it you got to go oh
yeah i'll do my smolder
you know i'd take you
that literally is where it came from
that what you're seeing and this is why
he looked at me because it's so
frustrating just go ahead tell tell the
story about your
stupid smell
it's one of those things that you know
as we're developing the script and think
well what could be a fun thing well what
a fun thing one of the fun things was he
he has this ability to smolder and it
just takes over him
he has no control of it uh and uh and
it's just one of those things
graham that god delivered i signed for
it and then
i just do it and everyone everyone likes
it and everyone loves it except one
individual
everyone loves i'm gonna tell you what
it is okay now we we are we are very
close we have our very closest friends
and you know in this position he's a
producer on the film so sometimes
i just bit my tongue so this idea came
up
from a producer like mentality oh you
know what would be great for this
character
if he's
you know if he did a thing and i was
like what that got to do with that being
like
in the game you don't have to see that
he's like it's a thing
and he's like and then he's brought him
back he's like my mom used to do it to
me when i was
everything got tied back to hawaii
that's how you did it graham
can we see a smolder can we see oh i'd
be happy to great sit back for a second
[Applause]
can we have a little music maybe
something that's a little ominous okay
here we go wow
yes okay okay here we go you can do it
to me
yes you're ready here we go
[Music]
[Applause]
yes
you have hung out with robert we've got
pictures of you here that that's one of
the rules is that your first world
variety second
that's the second one i mean that might
be why i'm not getting one
he's like i i came on a little strong to
prince william's girlfriend
not girlfriend so the duchess
the future queen sorry yes k midi i came
on
i came on quite strong and then when he
came down the line he went
uh uh seriously you need to stop
flirting with my misses
and so yeah that's me he's squeezing my
hand very hard
this is becoming a thing now as well i
um i
i've made no burns about it i'm a big
fan of um judy murray
of judy murray i think she's a wonderful
woman okay um
and you know i've said that publicly and
i went to queens
very publicly right now i went to queens
last week and
andy murray was there and i've never met
andy murray before and he beckoned me
over
and i went over like a little naughty
schoolboy and he went
jack you need to stop tweeting my mother
you want to see the dms
[Applause]
step dad that'd be great wouldn't it
that music you walked on to we did you
hear it i did yeah that's that's your
music
it is the iconic rock music
yes so did that bring back happy
memories of bad memories
oh happy memories oh good yes no i mean
i was able to do a lot of cool things
you know snoop was there on a couple
occasions yeah i was able to witness it
there was a lot of ass kicking going on
back there
yeah but we got the way this is the
classic i think this is our classic rock
pose
with the eyebrow that signature eyebrow
look at that
yes
and this is your kind of this is the
kind of the pre-match is this the
pre-match
yeah that's like the it's the pre-match
it's the preamble it's a talking trash
that is a i had a catch phrase that that
that went with is that it doesn't matter
that's it doesn't matter
how did it doesn't matter because it
doesn't sound like a catchphrase how did
it work as a catchphrase
well uh whoever i was in the ring with
and snoop has been there on many
occasions right so whoever i was in the
ring with so for example
if it were you and i i'd be like um
graham what do you think you're gonna do
tonight when we get in the ring
well i think it doesn't matter
that's how it kind of works that's how
it kind of works
and then the it's the shouting but then
if you smell if you smell what the rock
is cooking how did that work then in
in a sentence oh well that that works in
a sentence
uh a statement a question it works
anywhere right when you wake up right
before you go to bed it's just you could
just say it if you smell what the rock
is quick
yeah but you got to say it probably with
a little bit like you know you shout
that one as well
it's hard i generally have a microphone
when i'm doing it well hello
go for it
i don't know they don't want to hear me
okay all right here we go so it's it's
all starts with the base
okay okay you got to open your legs a
little bit okay okay
you got to kind of do one of these yeah
lean forward a little bit yeah okay
come back
and then right here is where you gotta
do a little tongue thing okay this is
what it gets interesting
if you smell it
then at the end you gotta now you gotta
do that what the rock
and then there's a little pause there's
like a big pregnant pause so you have to
do it right right
so the audience kind of leans in a
little bit is
cooking and then
because emily you're fluent in the
french as well absolutely not
oh i thought you were fluent i mean i
did it at school i did a level french
but i'd since gone out the window but i
i get really nervous speaking french and
i actually used to have
a stutter when i was a kid and it's
still
the way that that i still stutter when i
have to speak french
it comes out when it comes out when i
try to be friends yeah
weird yeah all right
i've seen the king's speech very
authentic portrayal
that was me i was colin first but in
french
but in french yeah we went to paris for
new year once and and
you know my now husband and our two
friends were like go on and find us a
taxi because we need to get to this
place
i said oh god please don't make me
please don't make me and i hadn't had
the guts to tell them actually i do
still stutter they were like go on
please and so i went to the guy at the
front desk i was like um
i could say everything apart from the
word taxi apparently so i went um
[Music]
and he went taxi and i went yes and he
went taxi
he's simon english silent
[Applause]
it was awful it was horrible
again that's it you take back
you reclaim the fanny pack or what we
call a bum bag bum bag yes
yeah yes i do i do well it started with
this picture i have an infamous picture
of me
uh in my 20s and i was just owning this
look i had a turtleneck i had mom jeans
on
i was wearing a face and we've got i
think we've got the picture here oh no
there you are
it's a strong look it's it's something
and this was this was you being serious
yeah no oh yes i
think i'm cool yeah this is full-on and
are you aware that this has now become a
sort of fancy dress outfit
like people do this they do this yeah as
a joke
seth rogen was on the show yeah and he
showed us his version here's seth rogen
as it
uh that's my guy
there's just a random man but very good
eye for detail
see he's got the tissue under the elbow
which you have here because let me just
give the audience context is what that
is the
the what i have my arm on was very dirty
so
i thought i need a tissue please to
protect the turtleneck
and it's not just adults no young fans
are attracted to it as well
and again again with the tissue i love
the rolex the tissue yeah
and actually some other people have done
it as well yeah check this out
[Applause]
the three of you should dress up and go
out in london tonight yeah the paparazzi
would go hysterical
like what's going on what's going on
school dreams aren't a touristy awful
i mean terrible things do happen on
school trips but you went to a very nice
school
so did you go on lovely things did you
just do very nice things on your school
trip
uh the worst school trip i ever went on
we went to hampton court
and uh we went there and they had
real tudor outfits you could try on one
for a man and one for a
for a girl but i went to an all boys
school and i was
chosen to wear the corset and dress
and i cried and it was awful and patrick
ward got to be the man so i had to be
patrick ward's for the afternoon
it was one of the worst experiences of
my life
actually i think that picture's in your
book we've got the picture
of we ramble in did you say yeah
look at that face
i mean i was actually i remember being
sad but in that photo i looked
i mean he looks haunting
and whispered that i'm not wearing any
knickers
he does look like he's just in denial
he's not going to remember this i'm
deliberately never going to remember
this happened
i could be in wolf hall do you think you
get bothered
all the time all the time yes but how do
you work with him
he's gone out the window but how do you
work out in the gym if people are
constantly giving up to you
just be nice say hello get them moving
and get them moving
but fame is a funny thing right so that
story for you well that will be like the
constant anchoring reminder right of
like how cool fame is but also
never like i don't have the stress you
have though because
i think the thing is if you if you are
five or six and you've got a hat on and
you're dressed like most of the time a
teenage boy in a baseball cap
headphones on head down i catch the bus
and i catch the bus on the subway
every single day because i'm not in
anyone's eye line like that but i
imagine
you there is something about if
if you're you you can't you're you're
seven feet tall
so yeah but kevin's kevin's had weird
you've had weird
fans well what happens if you're three
foot two like how does
that work
how do you do it what are you talking
about
no how do you deal with that you know
that hey look at that
five two i'm sorry right i'm trying you
swim with dolphins
no well i've taken up the hobby of scuba
diving
which i really really enjoy um and so we
went down i've been shark diving which
was kind of amazing i had a real close
encounter with a shark a little
low sharp it wasn't it was about six
feet so did it eat people
was it well it wasn't but why are you
trying to diminish myself just the type
of fish
you went near a fish let me tell people
that's your story i
[Music]
[Applause]
your stories rules for swimming with
dolphins
with dolphins i heard that you're not
supposed to
touch a dolphin unless they come to you
and offer themselves for a
rubbed oh you're not supposed to touch
them
if they don't because dolphins mate for
life and if you touch one of them the
other one can smell your
your touch on them and they think that
they've cheated on them and then you can
break up a dolphin marriage
that is true that is fact i know i'm
gonna have to phone up sea world
directly
i've been down one's blowout
well pull over faith she's had a dolphin
orgy if that's the case
yeah i reckon i've broken up a few
dolphin marriages i went to cuba
and i sort of was in a situation where
they were like
do you want to swim with dolphins and
they actually taught me how to
sort of be lifted up on the nose of two
dolphins and what with their
foot on each on these now if you think
she's making it up
somebody filmed it that's a good start
we've got the footage
not oh i was near a fish once
that's not nice let's have a look at
this yeah
i'm well into this now look oh brilliant
it's not great to begin with i'll give
you that it does look like a woman in
the water now
what's this what's what what
emily have you got any footage of you
near that fish
is it true that in moana that your
character
was based on him sure correct so
a lot of uh the uh the details of that
character
uh maui was based off of my grandfather
with a long hair and very big build and
tattoos
and in polynesian culture and samoan
culture um you
to become a high chief you have tattoos
um 360 degrees from your knees
uh all the way up to the bottom of your
chest everything
wow and and it's hardcore and they do it
with a tap
yes
everything everything no not everything
well
uh yeah that's what i heard i heard
everything yes working around well the
cash and prizes is
yes lifted yes and then you oh
yeah but because you've been in that
film now do you get
sort of children wanting you to kind of
delight them
as as maui all the time all the time
like
it's constant it's always constant oh
you sing songs sing your song sing your
song and
i'd do it and then and then they cheer
and then i go hey okay we'll have a good
day and then
sing again
constantly yes he has a great voice
saying oh thank you
you should sing to them
that's the last day
i i i can't i don't know if i
that look like a man who wants to i do i
don't know all right let's see
want some music go right into the wrap
part and this is what the kids love so
it's all right listen kid honestly i
could go on and on i could explain every
natural phenomenon
the tide the grass the ground oh that
was maui just messing around
i killed in the elena buried its guts
sprouted the tree now you got coconuts
what's the lesson what does it take away
don't mess with maui when he's on a
breakaway
and the tapestry here on my skin is a
map of the victories i win
look where i've been i make everything
happen look at that me mini man we just
took it to tappin
that's so impressive thank you